welcome to this video playing a
13-minute game against Susan from Mexico
yeah what should I play let's play a
Sicilian I don't play that too often not
quite sure why I am very the opening the
lot but Sicilian I rarely play well for
no particular reason I mean it's not
like I have no no idea about it I've
played various Sicilian lines over the
years and at least have forgotten
something that I might remember if if
it's really it's really necessary okay
sozin yeah well he's playing the
official system against the night off
while Bishop c4 is sometimes quite often
called the cells in system castles hmm
hmm i think b5 pit should be three there
should be seven s the way to play that
but should be seven I think there are
issues with them their issues with e6
should be six hmm okay yeah I really
have forgotten most of that queen of
three yeah Queen f3 is the main move
right here okay a 4 m-f for some that's
the way fish are played this really back
in the day Phil what's the right to
reply I don't really know yeah yeah
you'd like to
you like to play we should be seven and
i'm not sure i want to Castle my coby
should be seven and TC sacrificing I
have queen bee six check at the end zone
okay let's do that let's do that hmm
there are lines also with the cookie
five not sure that this is one of them
maybe takes takes Bishop c5 okay yeah f5
as mentioned is the classical way to do
that as fish are played I must play five
there's no no big debate about that I
can always consider before but i don't
think i can simply win the pawn I'm
quite positive that that's not possible
or at least does not really lead to
anything I need to play this first
anyway an important ideas if he tries to
yeah I have h5 this is a very important
with this is I think what Fisher did or
there was some game where h5 was was a
very strong resource intending h4 to get
to drive away the g3 night from this
from this Capcom this protecting post
and the H pawn can be a real nuisance
for white oh this is this is a very
weakening move with Bishop c5 and and
stuff like that
hmm naija for is also also very very
hard to meet already the question is
what is the best news
hmm jam lagi fourth it's not bad I'm
just thinking if I have something better
even yeah it's probably probably okay
night eh 5 mm yeah well I can play Queen
B 6 check yeah that's also a disaster
hmm damn ok it's probably enough do we
need to look for anything anything
better if it takes on h5 with the night
while rook takes Queen takes you four is
not even that is not bad ok but I have
Queen B 6 check which is the real point
King h1 night f'd which a group takes
Queen takes he can take g7 but after
King move at the end I'm meeting on the
edge file and I don't know what is what
he's doing now I mean I just threatened
to take edge form and I threaten Queen B
6 check and also which is maybe the
strongest d Fife is also a threat d5
takes in some way Bishop c5 check king
h1 Queen takes h4 checkmate yeah this is
some na bit of a desperation how to do
that now i mean i can i can give the
check on v6 mm-hmm I wonder I wonder
what's best and my team might have night
f5 this yeah it's not it's not like it's
not like that's blowing black away mmm
night eggs yeah come on this is simple
and good
getting this Knight to f6 winning a pawn
I still have queen bee six check well
here's cut the F file open now and i
must at least be aware of that that I
cannot simply move the f6 night as f7 in
saying to be honest I believe that the
old the old way here with f4 f5 as it
was played in some Fisher games I think
this is almost refuted to be honest I
mean I have really huge respect for
fisher but there's some some some time
has passed since he since he played this
this line and nowadays think FY find
this it is basically refuted um and he
played a very good game on the black
side of that it's not like he only
played with white this age five planner
is what he played her when he had black
okay queenie to let's um let's see he
has some covered f2 so i cannot just
play Queen B 6 check and and and win win
the exchange on f2 ya f 70 this is
slightly slightly annoying that I cannot
just move they have 69 if I want to just
the tech age for hmm John what to do 11
idea is just to play before yeah i think
i'm going to do that oh wait
wait just for a moment before I was
briefly thinking about Quincy for
attacking f7 but this is really nonsense
right yeah I have t5 at least d5 okay
this means i can I can play that driving
the the night away it does not have a
great square I mean if you go to d5 I'll
just I just take it and gain access to
the h4 pone ASI as I wanted and if he
plays 95 and i'll capture whatever piece
appears on d5 he also has the b3 f7
diagonal closed yes this is probably
what he needs to do and now I was
thinking if I am able even to play d5
just breaking the position open yeah
night f5 if he can play wit like i think
i can i can simply m can simply castle
after that
hmm
yeah yeah just just open this why not
and maybe it's got the capture and rook
to e1 I move like that and this is this
could be a bit a bit tricky now 95
wasn't good probably was not good wyd
least down there was something better
yeah Bishop takes is just plain rope do
you want them I have Queen a fire but
the night f5 oh yeah and that's not
really good what did i do them this was
not not really well played I take with
the night if I take what the night is
there oh yes maybe night f 5m yeah okay
come on I need to do that for anyway add
the 5d 5 was just too early now I can do
this can be a bit tricky i mean group d
1 I need to play Queen f5 and it's I
don't know it looks I don't really see
something great for white but yeah it
just feels a bit shaky and that's also
night f5 but ok night at five I can
probably yeah i can probably take here
and just castle yeah i really want to
take get to get out of the possible pin
with root d one night g7 checking evades
I mean there's just two pieces hanging I
don't believe that let's say you need to
still needs to capture that
okay so now I just castle right yeah
yeah this is fine this is fine again I
hope look to you one I just can go
Quincy seven something like that and I
have kept my extra pole and yeah I
probably didn't didn't play the the best
line this is quite quite clear but
that's probably good enough okay um yeah
this is an annoyance en the bishop one
night you to get the Queen out of this
may be here yeah maybe here so that I
can play a possible Bishop c5 check and
maybe at on a good day II for my twerk
Queen edge to mate if I before Queen
estimate but he's got bishop on their
forum at least yeah okay the good thing
is sized I I have the the pawn and he's
he's got an off-site piece on a 4g 5 +
f5 though I really nicely placed so
really no reason for me to to relax E or
anything
yeah I don't do I don't see anything
great though maybe it takes is no we
cannot do that I just thought 97 27
Knight b6 but they have Quincy five
check winning the the night now so
that's also not possible what would i
play if it was my move that's an
interesting question besides some simple
strengthening moves like I don't know
rock d 8 or something hmm yeah I can
think about that now because rookie one
slot and move that directly threaten
something at least I think hmm well I
can give this check on c5 but after King
King age one I don't really have
accomplished anything
and of course you can take it with the
night which which rather helps
Jeff I don't know 95mm getting getting
stuff exchanged the night on g4 always
protects five maybe come on I'm starting
to get a bit low on time yeah come on
let's exchange some some stuff trying to
simplify the position a bit
hmm Jim don't really don't really see
anything great for white
if it would be my move I probably just
take g5 and play Knight F for installing
get another night in years King wouldn't
be too bad I move that I need to be
aware of is Queen a7 check that's not
only Queen B 6 check which is covered at
the moment by the night on a form and
this was always the idea earlier Queen B
6 check but now I have Queen a7 check
this might be might be really useful
yeah I don't really yeah I don't see
anything great fun he can maybe try a
move like rook t1 this could be
interesting because I cannot move my
knight bitcoin is heaven hangs so after
um look to you one I take on d5 with the
bishop age takes g5 Alpine aight fo is
as mentioned and Bishop g5 rook takes d5
I just drop back probably to to f6 which
looks really solid I mean everything's
nicely protected yeah maybe you still
should do that unless he's got some some
real tactic going that I don't see it's
me it's possible I mean there are some
things hanging um move like so that's
not really heavily working ok let's not
waste time I was thinking about moves
like I know then you know not really he
cannot play a move like Knight b6 based
on the loose position of the seven night
I take it with a check home and to this
I mean
yeah next move I just move the night to
g6 probably and I'm just I'm just okay
then it's a very stable position on g6
covering e5 okay just takes it yeah now
i'm just i just have not a queen h4 and
the g3 is not really a move you want to
do maybe you must do you must play that
problem other than that I'll just take
edge for yeah I must play g3 and then
his night is still off side
yeah g 3 i'll i'll put a rock on on the
d file he cannot really oppose them
because of Queen e7 check the question
is which one yeah let's take that that
rook it's probably not so important
queen d Rock do you want it's not
playable due to Queen a7 check and then
there's a fork on f2 only 30 yeah it
looks this looks losers this looks loose
let's let's see I have this I have the
check and maybe even couldn't be seven
check just to improve the position a bit
but I can also just dislodge the rock
remember where is it going to go unless
he wants to return or give the exchange
which really does not not work okay how
to I'd like to double on the default of
course this would be would be basically
winning the enter on d 2 let's let's
check queen bees Knight b6 I'd like to
have this checks out probably here so
not roop d6 for example because of 95
it's probably not does not matter so
much um one negative thing about rugby
7s I don't have green am well that's a
bit stupid
hmm
yeah that's slightly stoopid I mean I
didn't think of that
who okay it's not it's not really the
end of the world but i thought was a bit
it was not too precise yeah if seven is
a tech team
Jeff what's the easiest I cannot go here
at least but you might have this check
at some point if I go f5 thinking about
f5 okay I keep it simple kappa f7 and
cover the two square cm c5 and b6 if he
goes Quincy for my intention was to play
Roxy 7y am here just just a green move
if he takes takes an ID be six days
Queen a seven using the pin yeah this
route 57 was bit stupid I mean probably
not spoiling much but certainly not the
best Queen a seven was a very useful
resource to have maybe I had some other
move on the default in Group D four or
so something like that okay at least
okay I'm Knight b6 of course Queen a
seven outs of Queen d4 check which is
much simpler so we cannot lose the night
again yeah then it give this chick 9ja
and he does not really have a good
square he will always run into a fork
like that check
this was why Queen a7 always was useful
okay first think a bit yeah that's it is
it is good let's just take it okay i can
i can give yet another check and then
use the pawn probably him that's good
jack white resigns yeah the h5 after h5
it was it was already a bit a bit tricky
for white and the computers already
giving me very big edge yeah i'm not one
hundred percent sure around here we are
still in some sort of theoretical
position but not a good one for white
and age for i think its trade it
straight away losing but yeah this is
the relatively best defense and around
here i can i can maybe improve you know
the easiest is probably just g6 i mean i
didn't want it I didn't want to move
upon him but it's probably the easiest
something like that must be must be
excellent now it is excellent yeah okay
well this is this not bad i mean it it
pushes the night on on the edge of the
board but Dee five hmm yeah the comp
does not find anything great for white
but it's this is slightly slightly shaky
looking with with Rob human-computer
quindi seffner merciless that's very
strong the other computer it's just it's
just not afraid of ghosts of course i
would have thought i would have played
queen a 5 which at least keeps a
baguette okay but 27 years
much stronger it looks as this square so
night f5s not possible it looks at a
form and this is of course nonsense yeah
because of the check so after up do you
127 he does not really have a good move
and after something let's say King knows
how to enable this kind of moves like
Knight b6 you just move the Queen to a
square wave out of the pin like here and
black has very good control no no
question yeah that's even stronger but
he played this after that I think I
should be okay yeah I'm 95 maybe this is
question would know day I was I was
always a bit in doubt if I played that
played it correctly but the computer is
not does not find anything anything
dangerous kiala okay this is not one
hundred percent precise but but it keeps
the winning hand ja ja ein does this
winter the exchange it's really down to
this opening I believe that nowadays
this F form even f4 is not they are they
usually play with queen of three and
then something like this Queen moves
there should be three Queen B seven
something like that as some is the the
the way they play it but I only have a
vague idea from some games that i know i
think it wasn't this the game
Mammadyarov galfond from the candidates
in Kazan 2011 something like that
something like that Queen g three
castles bishop age 698 something like
this might be even a theoretical
position yeah yeah
f4 is a bit outdated and frankly
speaking not so great okay thanks for
watching